Alright let's talk about Facebook have you
heard in this monstrosity this giant
company
that is stealing all your data you
signed up for those eyes that feeling
I'm not so sure you know what they're
doing with your data they are actually
doing bizarre
scientific tests at to depress you
yeah that's right we've got some info
for one week in early 2012 Facebook
change the content makes in the news
feed
about seven hundred thousand users some
were shown a higher number
a positive post while others were shown
more negative posts the study found that
users were shown more negative content
were slightly more likely to produce
negative posts users in
the positive group responded with more
upbeat posts okay
so we all talk about this all the time
the data and that we just give this step
away and we'd never read the Terms of
Service and weekly gas on everything
but now they're actually manipulating
things to alter
our mood am pretty sure nobody signed up
for that at
I keep pace but I talk about a consular
on the show that negative things make
people feel negatively
its sacks monstrosity is this I yes it
is crazy the theory
that negative things that make other
negative things crazy and how do you
know if you want the subject if you're
already depressed all the time like me
like I don't understand I'm they
probably would have left someone like
you out if they're out
my chat with him that I was part of the
experiment me feel a lot better about my
better behavior exactly I mean I'm
depressed by Mike distant cousins making
me play candy crush saga
so I really know how much worse ago okay
so should anyone be upset by this
really though because we sign up for
these things we know
we don't read the Terms of Service right
it's a fifty-page thing they just scroll
down click YES on
and then they're doing this to us but
it's a free service so do we have any
right
even to be upset we have a right to be
upset that
that they showed us things that were
depressing when we were using their free
service
that we signed up for we have a right to
be upset that we have any recourse
against them
it's it's it's their baby rector some
people are trying to get together and
pour some kinda lawsuit but I'm sure
that's not going to get you go to a
party voluntarily in the music bums you
out your welcome to leave
the I mean I'm master I most sides do
these things you know when they have
like two different versions for
different users and
in CNN different headlines for example
to see what a click on MORE you know
there are belt testing us
yes just probably giving you more a few
high school friends having babies
to perhaps and I i tonight does really
bummed me out but you know it's my
choice to be on Facebook into
for whatever reason befriend people
haven't seen in 12 years yet do you guys
ever find that the positive news
actually depresses you more than the
negative news you know to me like it
they there's some theory on this that if
you keep seeing your friends doing all
this cool stuff
by people just buy Instagram everyone's
food looks better than it actually is
and you think everyone's eating better
food than you so do you ever get more
depressed by the positive things that
you see people doing
than just the people who are suicidal
when it comes to Instagram I I'm really
torn between pictures other people's
food
and pictures /a girls feed on a beach in
for the bodies of water
yeah acts were torn between those two
people r us but our
you know I believe it was a ni Chiru
said we hate it when our friends become
successful
know that was marcy i yeah ask cause
yeah I me know I i mean if its a
positive news in the world grade
yes positive news for my friends I if
their friends and I love it's great if
their friends i'd
secretly hate them you know that's my
problem in it your but I mean if that's
a good
period like that I feel like if base
from just had more pose hash tag blast
that probably would be more homicidal by
the end of the day I
are you guys with me in the general
thing I just had it with Facebook I just
like anything that it's about now I only
have
fan page so I'm not involved in in all
the my new show
what's going on with their the feet and
everything which is this connectedness
is I'm just completely over and I said
no I would agree I love it I
yeah I love knowing the names of my
cousins hideous children I
I love being able to get back in touch
with the same guys who called me a
faggot to govern my hair in high school
yeah I you know being able to do that
and it but now you later here than it
being able to
being able to get you know which brat
pack member quizzes are you ten times a
day is in which we called
no I mean I I like Facebook I use
Facebook as a promotional tool is a
comedian
you know I have a standard I have a band
aid to have I have the all profiles a
stabbing a private page for my family
were just post baby pictures so Mike
cousins don't think I'm a leftist
monstrosity here
so how do I get a life you get what you
put into it and I'm
I don't really get so sucked into it
that I'm getting my email
information we Tapson things like that
no Facebook gaps
no Facebook axe science and the area so
you're doing it in a very controlled
kinda way
how do you manage your personal check
your facebook fanpage privilege does not
always have that are
that time I had actually know he dragged
me they I say that with all
do like grossness really no I mean I
love Facebook and similar
on Twitter you know it's a mixed bag and
I feel like it's a great promotional
tool on you use and
as you need to use it and you block
people willingly I mean I have a bunch
and I had this problem where a lot of
them involve me in facebook
we don't really know why but they do
yell at me and prevailing wage
and you talk about the Golden Girls
Aloud I do we get we silently know where
they came from but I do have a face for
problem with harassment
communist make a job and a bit because I
feel like it's a
the best way to handle things but his
much better with harassment Twitter
though because
yes actually have to show your name and
identity in most people don't go to the
trouble of putting together a
an alias as they do on Twitter on
Twitter these these these coward
child men can come out and call you
names
yeah yet they're protected by their own
anonymity that doesn't happen on
Facebook I have a policy
the Twitter party which is I won't fight
with an egg if you're just like Twitter
a guy will not
you fight with them and no I don't lie
you lie don't lie some Italian
I reach week I reach week the really
brilliant stuff that really funny stuff
and the really
I mean dumb stuff ya and you know check
I check their
check their follower count because it
fits in with 12 followers
no seeking getting these he lay moore's
yeah these guys would
these eggs with well I'm like he did
Twitter these girls here what you doing
what if I'm like this
but I honestly I I I think they can be
very instructive
and I think that you can use those
debates as away about
letting someone else hang themselves
creatively yeah it's a final thought on
this is there anything that would get
you to the point where you be willing
to actually get off facebook it likes of
the if you know they're doing
experiments on you
is there any point with which it would
just
you know the strong the camel's back
processing now and %um really honest
about it yourself bottoms-up morning
with my stuff on Facebook like
their its gonna say yeah are they do
anything with all this information even
if you're hiding it to the best you can
invest in Union Carbide they can be pay
yeah they could debut no funding baby
seal clubbing trips I mean there's a lot
of things to get done that was recovered
a
see you after I hate severe no lotta
things that can be done where I would
want to work
work want to withdraw my my my
membership but I i think that they're
smart businessman they create a fun
service
it is a great way to keep in touch with
relatives without having to actually see
them
and I think in that sense it's gonna be
around for a long time yeah all right
there you go
I hate Facebook Louis loves Facebook and
I'm game with
even-keeled answer on why may not be
killing off
up